I'm here to talk about Ai and shiny for
python now as I was working on my talk
uh I actually realized that it would be
better to talk about Ai and specifically
large language
models and how they fit in with systems
you know larger systems with humans and
other computer programs and sort of put
shiny in a in a supporting role for that
um so and when I talk about again when I
talk about a I'm referring to large
language models and when I talk about
large language models I'm mostly
referring to uh the ones by open API or
open AI I'm sorry which uh is you know
those are the best best known by far and
probably the most commonly
used all right so what is a large
language model well there's a lot of
different levels that you can look at
this question
um so at one level it's a neural network
and a neural network involves a lot of
Matrix math so there's a quote by uh
Simon Willison who's
um somebody who thinks about this stuff
a lot on his website these things are
giant binary Blobs of numbers anything
you can do with them anything you do
with them inv involves vast amounts of
matrix multiplication that's it uh there
it's an opaque
blob um that can do weird and
interesting things right so that's
that's one level another level is that
they are statistical models they make
predictions and the things that predict
our text you give it text and it'll
predict what the next word should be in
that text so um in a way it's similar to
uh the you know the keyboard on your
mobile
phone you write in some stuff there so
if I've written I would like a then it
gives me some possible next words and in
this case it's glass coffee and
cheeseburger all right now the model
that's used on your phone is going to be
way simpler than these large language
models that do the really interesting
stuff uh one other thing to know about
them is that um we don't really
understand how they think this was
actually really kind of confusing for me
at first it took me a while to really
internalize this but um we understand
how they work at a low level but you
know at a higher level we don't we don't
know how they like conceptualize a chair
or anything like that um it's sort of
still sort of a
mystery all right
now uh I showed you the text prediction
and we're all familiar with chat GPT so
one question you might have is how do
you create a conversation um with word
prediction how do you you know if I'm
just predicting predicting the next word
in the string like how does it work um
when there's a back and forth between
two
people so um it's actually pretty simple
there's the input and uh it looks
something like this so there's a string
here and I say user colon why is the sky
blue um and then I continue the string
and the next line I say assistant colon
and then I close the string and so you
give that to the
model and um it will return an output
that looks like this the sky clear is
blue because dot dot dot so really uh
what I've done is I've prompted it to
you know to take part in a dialogue um
and it knows to fill in the rest of it
so that's that's how it does it with um
uh with this word
prediction so this sort of chat
interface has been really nously
successful I me we all know about chat
GPT and uh I did some I did some work
earlier this year on a python package
called chat stream which you can use to
make AI chat apps with shiny so I'm
going to show you a really basic app
made with
this um all right so this this is
basically like chat GPT you know you can
type in your question so why is the sky
blue and it gives you an
answer and why not red and it gives you
another answer and it it does that by
talking to the open AI
API that's how it gets those answers and
to create an application like this this
particular application it's really it's
really simple so um we got the normal
shiny stuff there there's the UI and
server parts of the of the app um and
then we say chat stream. Chi and you
give it an ID in this case my chat and
then in the server part we say uh chat
stream. chat server my chat and then
that's that's all you need to do well
and you need to get an API key but those
are the things you need to do to make uh
that simple
application okay now before we do more
interesting things with this it will be
useful to sort of understand what how it
talks to the openai
API so when you ask it a question it
makes a request to the API and that
request is uh just some Json text or
Json that contains some text so uh it
has this part of the message says roll
system content you are a helpful
assistant that is the system
prompt and that's normally that's not
something that you Norm most users
interact with that's just sort of
usually hidden all right and then there
is uh the actual question roll user why
is the sky blue all right so it sends
that message over to the API and then it
gets a response and the response comes
back roll assistant content and then
there's there's an answer that uh the
llm has generated Now to turn this into
a
conversation um we make another request
so just so you know that on the on on
their servers uh they don't record the
or well they don't they don't keep track
of the state of this conversation it's
stateless they actually do record this
stuff so um for reasons I guess anyway
so we make another request and we
include the previous information that we
had and then we also tack onto it the
reply that it gave us to us earlier and
then we can ask our next question right
so R user content why not
red and then it sends another response
all right so this is how the
conversation works so every time every
time I add something to the conversation
I I'm actually um I have to send it the
whole previous
conversation all right now um one other
interesting thing about this was that
that that system prompt so you know you
hear a lot about prompt engineering I
put it in quotes because it's seems like
kind of um that seems a little bit like
an exaggeration calling it engineering
but um you can change that so to have to
change the behavior of of the responses
that it gives you
so we can give it this prompt like uh RO
system content you are a sarcastic
teenager and if you're using chat stream
uh you can just pass it in as an
argument to the chat server
function and so now when you ask it why
is a sky blue it'll say oh I don't know
maybe because it's too cool to be in
other
color all
right all right so I'm going to go to
show show you some more examples of this
of using chat stream but
um uh first I want to talk a little bit
about how llms fit into systems that you
might build so so in these with systems
you know with humans and computers um
well there's obviously humans so humans
can do many different things um but we
have unpredictable behavior and we
easily get tired and bored and I know
that's especially true for me uh then we
have computer programs which are really
good at doing the things that they're
specifically designed to do uh they're
very predict predictable behavior and
they never get tired of
board and um then we also have l LS
which obviously are computer programs
but I'm going to categorize them
differently here they can do many things
and they're often surprising it's often
surprising what they can do um the
behavior is trained it's not
designed um and the behavior is not
completely
predictable and like regular computer
programs though they also never get
tired or
bored so with all that in mind uh let's
look at uh let's look at a practical use
case so uh I sometimes look for recipes
on the internet and uh I Google them and
I end up at websites like this all right
so this is Real Deal sesame
noodles and so you go to a web page like
this there's some text at the beginning
uh some beautiful
pictures some text sesame noodles a
symphony of flavor advertisements
pictures a lot of ingredients very easy
to
make pop-up
advertisement the Sesame noodle sauce
isn't just for noodles
more pictures make your own chili oil if
you can how to serve sesame noodles
better too much sauce than too little
all right so it justes a lot of this
stuff more pictures and then finally we
get down to here where the where the
recipe is um now suppose you want to
take this information and put it in a
database like I want to I want to you
know keep track of some recipes that I
that I
like well that that's converting that
would be converting unru structured data
to structured data so um taking that
website and turn it into a format that
you can put into a
database now computer programs aren't
very good at this because the input is
too messy like maybe I could write
something that could extract the the
recipe out of that particular website
but if I just sent it to some arbitrary
other website it would you know
completely fail and have to write a new
program to do
that people aren't good at that because
it's too
boring and uh but it turns out that llms
are very good at this and um it's it's
almost magic how good they are at doing
these sorts of things so if we build an
application to do this for us um we have
a few components so first there's the
web interface to make it easy for the
human to
[Music]
interact okay then we have python to do
the computery stuff like uh fetching the
web page and scraping text and also you
know running the web server and uh for
the shiny app and all that and we also
have an llm which takes the unstructured
text and synthesize structure data out
of it so let's take a look at how an a
program like this would work in
practice okay so we could enter in the
recipe
URL and um this is the llm returning to
us the recipe and Json format which then
we can do you know we can do something
with like put it in a
database now there is one more thing in
here that I sort of uh glossed over
which is the um the prompt so they
didn't just you know like I just gave it
a URL and it magically did this uh I did
have to give it a little bit of a hint
of what it should be doing with that
with the URL so or sorry with the text
that I got from the URL so this is the
system prompt that I use for this
application your goal is to extract
recipe content from text and return a
Json representation of the useful
information the Json should be
structured like this and then I give it
an example right and that example is
very helpful it's very important so that
it'll give me the right thing so I gave
it that example
and then this is the output that it it
returned which is you know structured in
just exactly the same way um and it's
actually cool it adds some extra things
in there like uh oh it's at the very
bottom of the slide added tags like uh
it's a side and it's I can't remember
what else but but so that if you want to
search for it in the database you could
do that um even though that those things
weren't present in the original uh in
the original web page it just figured
that out because it knows something
about sesame
noodles okay so uh that's really that's
really useful having this this
structured data but you might find that
you need to validate the output from the
llm so as I said earlier the the llm
output is not completely
predictable uh like if I sent it to I
mean it worked for that particular
recipe but if I sent it to another
website or got another recipe it might
mess it up somehow you can't be
completely sure that it's going to do
the right thing that's one of the
annoying things about them but
we can use a human to validate the
output problem with that is that reading
the Json is hard and it's
boring and for but fortunately we can
use the computer to do computery things
to make the structured data easier for
human
consumption all right so let me show you
what this application would look like um
we will enter in that uh that recipe URL
again but this
time we when we render it we have shiny
taking that Json and rendering it into
HTML so that it's easier for us to look
at so we can look at that and inspect it
and say hey does this this looks like a
proper recipe it looks correct and then
uh after we the human inspects it then
we can continue and say click on ADD
recipe and add that to our
database all
right okay another thing that you may
want to do is uh augment the knowledge
of your large language model so for open
AI I believe uh their knowledge cut off
dates are in beginning of 2022 now so
for example they don't know anything
about shiny for python if you ask it um
if you ask ask it about shiny for Python
and ask it to generate an app uh it'll
just hallucinate something or you know
it'll it'll give you some a streamlet
app or a Dash
app
but we do have a lot of shiny for python
documentation which you can actually you
can actually give it to this to the
large language model so in order to do
that um I of over the procedure here so
you can have the computer break up the
document into text pieces and store them
in a vector database and uh
unfortunately I don't have time to go
into how the vector database works but
um it'll store them in the vector
database so then uh when a human asks a
question about the document or our
documents um the computer can use the
vector database and extract possibly
relevant pieces of text it's sort of
it's It's a probabilistic thing it'll
extract pie pieces of text that it
thinks are probably relevant um and just
sort of sticks those all together all
those pieces of text together and send
them to the LM along with the
question so then the llm ingests that
text and synthesizes something useful
for the human so if my question is uh
show me how to build a basic shiny for
python application uh from the vector
database it might extract all these
pieces of text uh you don't have to you
know you don't have to read them but
these are just chunks of text and some
of them are relevant and some of them
might not be and they all get sent to
the large language model so let's see
this in in uh in
action so show me how to create a basic
shiny for python application
and there it is it's return the code for
a basic shiny app shiny for python app
which again you know the the GPT models
don't actually know about them uh
they've they're only informed about them
from our this this information that we
just sent
it I can ask you know how do I deploy
this application to posit connect and
then it provides that information as
well um so one thing I want to point out
is that in this particular app you can
see that there's a model drop down
selector it's using GPT 3.5 turbo 16k um
the 16k means it's that's the amount of
tokens it can take for the context that
means um the default is 4K the 16k means
you can provide it with a lot more
information which is really useful when
you're doing this because those pieces
of text that are sent over are again
they're not necessarily relevant they're
probably relevant so adding throwing
more of them in there is
helpful all right so um some takeaways
this is this is last slide um so humans
normal computer programs and llms are
good at different things and uh we can
combine them together to play to their
strengths and when it comes to shiny
it's shiny is useful bridge between
human and computer programs and chat
stream can help you build AI chat apps
with
shine so
thanks thank you so much we have time
for a few questions um the first one is
can you run this app on shiny
live yes well it so I there is a version
of chat stream where I've I sort of had
to hack it to to get it to talk to the
openai
API but then you also have to have your
API key sent along with the shiny live
application so whoever is running that
shiny live applic live application will
have your uh openai API key which is
probably not a good idea but I mean if
you trust them if it's like for
something internal maybe that could work
and but again that's also that was also
a special like weird version of chat
stream that um I'm not sure I hav a
branch yet but I have code for it
somewhere uh next can we leverage
different llms available such as llama 2
instead of the open AI API in chat
stream um currently no I think getting
that to work would be pretty
straightforward because the the API
communication is pretty simple you just
you know you send it a Json message and
it sends you something back and it
there's there is a streaming aspect of
it so I think uh it probably would not
be too hard to modularize the Llama
2 um protocol but I have not tried it
before so I can't say that for sure and
last question um can chat stream output
uh be other content such as
plots
um well it no it can't because um open a
will just give you text so it doesn't do
plots although um well you could run
some code from them to generate plots
and then render those using
shiny um I know George has experimented
with that a little bit but uh I won't I
don't I can't say too much about that
now because it's just experimental thing
thank you so much um this is
Winston
you